♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-But first, we're going to need
another player,
and we found a great one.
From "Saturday Night Live,"
Emmy-nominated Leslie Jones!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa!
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
Coming in hot!
Coming in hot on that one.
Coming in hot.
-Zero to 60 in 2 seconds.
-There we go.
Thank you for joining us.
Leslie,
now, here's how the game works.
In front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One of the envelopes
is something
that actually happened to us
in real life.
The other envelope is a lie.
-Mm.
Once you read your confession,
the two other players
have 60 seconds
to interrogate you,
and then they each have to guess
whether you have been lying
or telling the truth.
-Hmm.
-Mm. Mm-hmm.
-I don't know if you'll be --
I-I think that you'll be bad
at lying
'cause I think
you're a very honest person.
You're very --
-Yes, I am.
-Yeah.
-But I lie a lot, too.
-[ Laughs ] I don't know if I --
I don't know if I believe it.
Not sure if I believe that.
-I'm not sure if that's a lie...
-I know. Exactly.
-...or truth.
[ Laughter ]
-Already, the game is tricky.
Keegan, you'll go first.
Leslie, which envelope
should Keegan open?
-I want him to open envelope 2.
-A-ha.
Number 2.
-Number 2.
-Number 2. Yeah.
-Oh, here we are.
-What is the truth or lie?
-Let's see.
Okay.
Oh.
Mm-hmm.
-Okay. This could all be part
of the -- the ruse.
-[ Clears throat ]
I got paid...
-Uh-huh.
-...to dress as a caveman
for a singing telegram company.
[ Laughter ]
-What year was this?
-I was just going to say that.
-That's not real coffee.
Sorry.
-Whoo.
What is that?
-I don't know what that is.
It's colored water.
It's all prop.
It's all a prop.
Don't drink.
And that's not a real cigarette.
What year was this?
-I'm sorry, Jimmy.
What? What?
-This is Drano.
This is Liquid Drano.
Yeah, don't drink --
Don't use the props.
-Whoo!
-Are you okay?
-I'm okay. I'm all right.
I'm back.
-Start the clock.
Let's restart the clock at 60
if we could.
-[ Sighs ]
-What year was this?
-Nine--
-Hmm.
-What do you mean, "nine"?
-19.
-Like, it's going to be what,
1900?
-19 -- 19 --
-I knew it was 19-something.
-19 what?
-1993?
-Okay. '93.
Are you in high school
at this point?
♪♪
[ Light laughter ]
-No.
-Yeah, no.
-Were -- Were you at Mercy --
-University of Detroit?
[ Laughter ]
-Were you in Detroit?
-Yes, yes, I was.
Yes, I was in Detroit.
I was in Detroit.
-Was you doing comedy
at the time?
-I...was...n-not doing comedy
at the time, Ms. Jones,
Detective Jones.
-No?
Did your caveman have a name?
-Bamook-ook.
[ Laughter ]
-That sounds so racist.
-Yeah, I know.
Now, hey.
That is -- Did you --
Did you have to sing?
[ Buzzer ]
-Aw!
-Whoo!
-Bamook-ook.
-I didn't get
to ask no questions.
I would have guessed it.
-You would have guessed it
right on.
-I think he's telling the truth.
[ Drumroll ]
-Struggling actor?
-Exactly.
-You take any gig you can.
I think you're telling
the truth.
Yeah.
-Well...
the both of you [Chuckles]
are absolutely correct.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You did?
-I did.
-You got to take a gig.
Leslie, you're right.
-She got it.
She didn't even have to ask
a question.
-I know she has
a couple of them.
-And I had to say
racist stuff and everything,
and they still guessed it.
-I know.
I know what's up.
-I love you having to do that.
Oh, I love that you did that.
All right.
-I wish this was a joint.
-It's my turn.
It's not. It's all props.
[ Laughter ]
-This would be so much funner
with a joint.
-All right.
-But you'd have to put
60 minutes on the clock.
[ Laughter ]
[ Scattered cheers
and applause ]
-Which envelope should I open?
1 or 2?
-Jimmy, you will open
envelope number 1.
-Number 1.
-Mm-hmm.
-Mm.
-[ Snorts ]
[ Laughter ]
I once rode on the back
of a jet ski with Madonna.
[ Laughter ]
-What year was this?
-That. Mm-hmm.
-2011.
-Oh, I know that's a lie
because Madonna's like 75.
She ain't --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, that's not true.
-That's a lie.
Madonna not fittin' to get
on no ski.
She not about to get
on no ski jet at 75.
-Jet -- "Ski jet."
A jet ski.
-A jet ski.
-Ski jet, jet ski --
She's not getting on it.
-She ain't getting on it
either way.
-She's 75.
-All right.
-Let me a-- There's no insurance
for that.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Let me ask you a question.
What body of water...
-Exactly.
-...were you on this jet ski
with Madonna?
-We were in The Hamptons.
It was the ocean.
-Okay, that's another lie
because Madonna don't go
to The Hamptons.
-She does.
-I know this for sure.
-Mm-hmm.
-Because she's a material girl.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What does that mean?
-They don't go to The Hamptons.
-Okay.
-Now, listen, I'm the good cop.
You don't want anymore of this.
-Seven seconds.
Uh, did you hurt yourself
during the trip?
-No, but we didn't talk at --
the whole --
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh.
They didn't talk.
-They didn't talk.
They didn't talk?
-That might be the truth, then,
because Madonna don't like
white people.
-No, she does not like
[ Laughter ]
-She doesn't.
-I mean, she won't even --
She won't even talk
to half of me.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know.
I'm tryin' to...
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, you know.
What do you think of this?
-I think he --
I think he lying.
-I think it's a lie, too.
I'm going to go with her gut.
I'm going to say it's a lie.
-Of course it's a lie.
I've never been on a jet ski.
♪♪
How did you guess that?
Madonna -- I don't think
Madonna would ever jet-ski.
-No, no.
-I said she's 75!
-No, not because that.
I just think she's too cool
to jet-ski.
She's like, "I don't do that.
You do it."
-Nope.
-Yeah, all right. I thought --
I thought I was
going to need longer,
I'd get in
to a whole fake story,
and then you bust me
right off the top.
-That's because I know liars.
-Okay. All right.
Here we go. All right.
-Especially if you are male.
[ Women cheer ]
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Never -- Why would I ever lie
about jet-skiing with Madonna?
Okay, here we go.
Leslie, it's your turn.
I'll choose the envelope.
I say...number 1!
-Yeah! Okay.
Let's see what's in number 1.
Um...okay.
Oh.
Okay.
During the 2016 Olympics,
I got lost in Rio
and got a ride home
from a man on a horse.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, let me ask a question.
-Yes, baby.
-Did you get a ride home...
all the way to New York City?
[ Laughter ]
And did the horse die
halfway through,
and the man had to drive up
and piggyback you
the rest of the way?
-There's no way
this is a real question.
-That's a dumb-ass question.
-All right, now, look.
Now, look.
Was the man a cop?
Was he a police --
Was he a police officer?
-Nope.
-It was a random guy -- Where --
Where were the Olympics again?
-First of all, we in Rio, dude.
Okay?
-Yeah, so, you're in Brazil.
There's a dude on a horse.
-There's dudes on mopeds,
horses,
all kinds of stuff there.
-And how -- Why would you even
think in your life
to get on a horse
on the way home?
You couldn't get a ride
somewhere?
-If you would have seen
this dude...
-Was it Fabio or something?
-He was Fabio-ish.
-Was he -- Was he an athlete
at the Games?
-No, but he was an athlete
at the games.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Drumroll ]
-That came out --
That came out too confidently.
-Yeah, I agree.
-That came out too confidently.
-Too confidently.
-That's true.
This is true.
-That is true.
-That is a true statement.
-This is absolutely a lie,
fellas.
-Oh!
-Oh, my gosh!
What?!
-That's not --
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?!
The best at playing the game!
Leslie Jones!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Keegan-Michael Key!
We're talking to Leslie
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
You lie!